- Dans cbanlieue parisienne,
la cinquième vague exerce
une pression continue. Karim
y a été admis il y a trois
patients ici sauf un, il n'est
pas vacciné et plein de remords.
- Si je me sens mieux,
il faut que j'aille... il faut
Je conseille à tout le monde
d'aller se faire vaccinercrcrce
que toutes ces conneries-là
qu'on entend dans votre tête,
YouTube, la théorie du complot,
toutes ces conneries-là,
il faut... il faut vraiment
le personnel soignant l'entend
souvent, aouououour avouer
un certain agacement.
SANDY JEBAHI, infirmière
bien, en fait, dès qu'ils
sorticicicici, ils vont se faire
vacciner. Mais j'ai envie
de leur dire : déjà, il faut
- Face à une augmentation
f f f flèche des nouvelles
contaminations et la propagation
inédite du variant Omicron,esess
de vaccination.
- Il vous faut cette dose,
sinon vous perdez
- Le passeport sanitaire des
plusnsnsnsnsns n'est désormais
plus valide sans une troisième
dose. Et depuis aujourd'hui,
jugés vulnérables peuvent
trtrtrtrtre vaccinés.
Dans une demi-douzaine de pays
européens, dont l'Italie,
ce sont tous les enfants de plus
de 5 ans qui relèvent la manc
au son des encouragements
enthousiastes de leurs parents,
après une petite piqûre.
"Ce qui m'inquiète, c'est
que nous voyons maintenant
le nouveau variant Omicron
à l'horizmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm.
On nous dit qu'à la mi-janvier,
nous devrions nous attendre
à ce qu'Omicron soit le nouveau
va Dans le contexte, l'Italie
a annoncé un durcissement
des conditions d'entrée sur son
territoire pour les voyageurs en
dès jeudi. La Grande-Bretagne
s'est peut-être retiré
de l'Union européenne il y a
bientôt un an, elle n'en est pas
cinquième vague. Au contraire.
Avec 78 610 cas posi
enregistrés en 24 heures,
la pandémie en 2020, le premier
ministhnhnhnhnhnhnhnson, parle
d'un raz-de-marée.
Il souhaite que son pays
arrive àununununununun million e
personnes par jour. S'ils sont
très nombreux depuis 48 heures
pour obtenir une troisième dose,
cenononononononouvelles mesures
anti-COVID, comme le télétravail
obligatoire, le port du masque
sanitaire pour les grandsenenené
une rébellion sans précédent
au sein même de ses trou
"Je comprends le sentiment
considèrent comme des atteintes
à la  B B B B B B B Boris
Johnson. Et nous avons essayé
tout au long de cette pandémie
de maintenir nos vies",
s'........
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
et les règles, c'est le virus.nn
diffusée en soirée, Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas exclu queeeeeeeee
des mesures sanitaires plus
popopopopopopopourraient être
annoncées dès vendredi.